i get it because like sometimes i'm just
like i don't want to watch anime today
but like i kind of got to you know
whereas because like
yeah because i'm like i'm like
how can you complain about [ __ ]
watching anime or like reading manga i'm
like that sounds like an amazing job and
i'm just like most of it's [ __ ]
i do watch a lot of [ __ ] as well but
like how do you do it you have like a
technique you only watch like every
other day
i have a technique he's watching he's
watching four at once yeah
it's actually i actually like some shows
i have to watch at times two speed yeah
that's that that has been like the
lifestyle well that's me was youtuber
every video i watched two times like i i
yeah what every youtube video because i
think about it like if i think about it
okay 40 minute long video two times
speed that's 20 minutes i saved 20
minutes yeah but yeah but can you not
like i because i i've done that before
as well just to like test it out like
half the videos i watch i don't
understand what the [ __ ] is happening
it's like too fast if you're doing
enough your brain could be like ah but
like it's for me it's like commodifying
entertainment you're like turning it
into like a chat
okay it depends it's talking it's like
family guy speaking okay no
it depends right it depends if i'm like
if if there's a video in which i am just
trying to get information out of this
video like a tutorial or maybe i'm like
watching you know phillyd and i'm just
like i just want to hear the news said
to me i just need to like consume
information i feel idea two times speed
he talks it two times
one time so
you watch entertainment and due time
speed no no only if they're talking
mostly if the visuals are like you know
like animation or uh i don't know
something
yeah talking that's everything ever
yeah yeah that's mostly youtube they're
they're talking so much
netflix you're watching two times no
yeah so why youtube and not netflix i
feel like youtube is like more like
background consumable kind of like
content and netflix is like i want to
sit down on my couch and watch something
yeah yeah you know what's like that kind
of like netflix styled content on
youtube at all like you don't watch like
only watching
yeah
like like i get it because like my video
is like two times slower
[Laughter]
that's the thing it's like when i when i
take off two times speed i go to normal
speed i'm like are you so slow i've
sometimes you just like you play a video
and you forget which speed it's that you
have to check it's like is this normal
speed or two oh it's 1.5 times i've
forgotten what like a normal speaking
place is right now because like because
everyone talks at a different pace but
like i like the same tempo with like
everyone i listen to i guess we'll end
up like with like the wally movie dude
like what we'll end up in the space show
people like you
he's actually like sonic you know
consuming like not ever enjoying
anything yeah
molly was right dude i do enjoy it like
what information am i leaving out
nothing i'm still listening to the whole
video you could imagine this
effort to set up the shop
there are some videos that need to be
watched [ __ ] 1.5 and there are stuff
like that where it's not it's not just
tutorials people talk too slow but like
99 of videos should just be watched in
the [ __ ] speed yeah
i think it's about 50 50. like to me to
me it's about 50 50. there are some
pieces of content yeah i'm not saying i
will watch all two times drama videos
where you just like hear about like news
with like other [ __ ] creators or
whatever that is not something i need to
watch at like one time speed man like
[ __ ] that and tutorial videos are the
only ones i can think of and like if
you're watching like a documentary or
something that's like one time speed you
know if it's like heavily edited you
know it's it's it's one time speed if
it's just like a guy if it's like a guy
in front of a camera just like talking
about a topic or something i'm like
don't watch this i just don't watch
you watch a lot more of those videos
than you think you do five or a 1.5 yeah
yeah yeah do you watch like asmr videos
at two times
1.25 i can kind of get a little bit
behind but like two is just too fast one
point
like to me like two is seven five
like i haven't gotten to like the
two-time speed meta yeah i guess
people just look at the time stamp and
they're like i can go faster
that i i want to do this faster hey you
saved 20
minutes your is your objective poop
session is your objective to just
consume more like what are you trying to
achieve by i'm not trying to consume
more i'm just like like if it's
background noise what's the problem with
leaving at one time speed well okay
i'll make it slow so i could join the
background you see you used to watch
trash taste before you uh felt like it
was parasocial
yeah yeah oh my god
was [ __ ] brutal man i couldn't do it
did you watch trash taste in two times
speed
um i tried it i was like emily let's
watch it at 1.5 speed she's like no
no because like it's like to me if i'm
watching it
yeah so to be fair like if i'm watching
at 1.5 speed i am like paying attention
so i'm like i'm like very consciously
paying attention if it's in the
background it has to be like a one one
one time speed but like say to me it's
just like yeah you you are consuming
like you are consuming this content and
that's why i watch it at 1.5 to two
times speed whatever but like there is
some content that is like it's
technically entertainment but the
entertainment is gathering then getting
the information that this person is like
portraying i guess i don't know it's
it's really weird right it's really
weird that's the funny part is that if
if i am alone though i will watch trash
tasty
goddammit
guess what i save a two hour long video
i save an hour i guess i guess i guess
it's better than mood on who edits this
[ __ ] at four times yeah yeah just
sitting there doing nothing else
watching traffic no i'm listening is it
can you listen at two times speed and
still do something else that's like i
can't hear anything dude listen you
when you read a whole book and it
flashes the words like really fast
like and you could read the whole book
what the [ __ ] you talking about you
never see that if they if there's a
thing on an image or like whatever yeah
they could they say like oh you can read
this book really fast if you just flash
the words like
it's the same thing like if your brain
isn't
your brain if you watch too much two
times speed
you you you can't use your kidneys you
can speed up the brain's processing yeah
no you're not overclocked
in your brain
[Laughter]
so it was fine limitlessly
the limitless advice is saying man and
watching this stuff in
that's why it's a feature on youtube you
know it wouldn't be a feature of a lot
of people when using it you know
yeah but at the same time there must be
some people who can only watch videos at
point five speed oh dude two or five
speeds no no no that's that's
yeah maybe they take a while to process
it
maybe if you don't speak english very
well you know it's your second language
i mean some phillyd videos i have to
watch a point five speakers i'm like
you're talking too fast really
like figuratively yeah i'm like i wish i
could i think led is like 1.75 one point
it's like it's not quite
it's not quite
i mean it's just it's just like
you know how like when you've read manga
you can like pick pick like the pace
you're reading at right yeah yeah so
everyone has a different pace right yeah
but like slow with monkeys yeah yeah you
like the art so so the way i see it is
that it's just you're you're picking the
pace in which you like are you able to
get this like information because like
why is it why is it any different from
like speeding through a few pages versus
some people who really want to like look
at the artwork and you know appreciate
what's being drawn and some people are
just like all right
there we go you know that's how i see it
because it's the difference between like
the treadmill and the exercise bike
right the treadmill you pick the speeds
and then like you've got to try and keep
up with it yeah because the bike is like
it's as fast as you can make it go yeah
right you're what i mean that's a good
analogy so like it's not it's not the
same action right because you're reading
and it's like you're putting an effort
to read this thing so obviously you can
push it but if you're if the treadmill's
going too fast you can't keep up well
you're not reading a manga no no you
have 20 seconds
no but what i am saying is like if you
set it out of speed while you can keep
up then which reminds me yeah speaking
of pacing
and poop pooping
okay that was the weirdest [ __ ]
tangent i've ever had
okay
so i i take my sweet time on the toilet
yes i am also a dude yeah heated toilet
of course yeah yeah now the the bidet
yeah oh god
it's [ __ ] amazing
so emily emily pees longer than she
poops i swear to god i say this a lot
but actually that's true yeah and she's
like why you poop so long and it's
because
it's like the best time i love pooping i
agree i agree i love it as well what
made you bring this up
oh because i heard poop and i heard
people you i did not say poop you said
you said
i did not say food
mudan rewind the clip i did not say food
okay that was poop and then manga
because i read my manga all in the
toilet right i only read manga on the
toilet so then when you said manga i
thought of bathroom
and then you said
he said he's just some weird pavlov
he's like reading and he just wants to
[ __ ]
this this is like that scene where like
sherlock is like picking like the
[ __ ] like words out of the air you
know
it's like pacing poop
manga
i can make this a tangent
because everybody takes their time on
the toilet or not yeah yeah yeah yeah i
get that and i love the toilet